321 pai ó pessoal do que falar andar que
sejam muito bem vindos em mais um vídeo
e eu os trato já que lá é zero pois fui
muito feliz lá foi tranqüila e autônomo
em outubro para gravar este por isso eu
também vou gravar porque eu sou o tubo
não eu sou simplesmente disse anta este
é o homem menu é e que vocês podem
escolher o vosso novo e wall street por
seu lado no original é senhor rebu senão
não possuir um bom brinca ora aqui está
o porquê de ser um justiça obriga ou
seja este o beque ghoga ai meu deus vou
cometer o uol a fofa
quero escolhe é basicamente tipo igual a
galo mas tem a particularidade de vocês
serem pulmão briga ver recuando jorge y
qual é o objetivo do i still here fugir
destas cobras contra nós é basicamente
está aqui porque é um jogo do nosso quem
sabe você gera um copo de vinho comendo
as maçãs mas neste caso vocês comem tipo
bola sociais do universo inteiro à
gauhati do estilo e é e desfrute estamos
muito e como é que uma cobra se
perguntam vocês eu também não sair eu
acho que de frente contra elas neckarelz
quanto mais pequenas mais rápidos são
então é difícil até agora é que ela não
conseguiu meu é muito boa essa cobra
ainda não vi ninguém leva vamos tentar
apanhar alguém não é possível é uma
cobra coxa agora dói aquela como o
robusto também quero estar em um
tutorial não e nos passos da alstom
ferrari descobre só pra mim achar
percebi quanto mais nosso juízo mas
porque eles ficam é o caso do ano
tranqüilo e vou tentar e isso é o que
comer
o conselho como era o valor não é
proibir não só como eu fiquei grande
para caraças e eu vou tentar entrar no
link o top 10 o grupo está comigo uma
cobra entretanto nem olhei mil e bocha
tudo em grande meu olho só pra mim pô
meu deus que eu sou muito profissional
eu tento não comer e oum daqui mais
pitéu para que não pudesse sptel a eu
estou a entrar num lugar muito perigoso
eu acho que é uma cidade que não há
exatamente calmas
o zoo o dólar já forçou ano
e aí morrer ae
olha aqui tanta comida a vala na hora de
comer aí aí não não gira e do demônio
meu é fato que todos o avião só por
tentar alimentar uma lombriga esta sim é
uma lombriga ou isso não é uma lombriga
de deus meu olho eu só vou a maior briga
do jogo
eu sou muito forte eu sou muito eu curso
que mataram briga maior de jogo e agora
só agora temos que conquistar aqui um
dos brics
este tipo de estratégia sério eu consigo
ver a minha exploração do pau louca não
está piadas públicos
isto é pior do que o hiv o op é quase
que era comida agora vou tentar comer
esta não é já esta já muita comida aqui
olha só como olha só o pitéu mil via
hoje está um manjar dos deuses vai
contudo contudo dark vai lá vai ter até
hoje tira deus como uma cobra se
conseguir com as quase que era comida
agora eu vou tentar comer alguém aí eu
caí agora faço agora vai isso obriga
agora vai ficar a maior briga tona sahel
chuva que não pode é o chuchu não não é
hora para a outra mala ela tentou cercar
e eu ainda consegui escapar minha
opinião uma [ __ ] das brigas ou ainda
uma tarefa e não vou matar esta escolha
só quero comer tudo não pode ser muito
perdeu anderson pai doença é mais que
deu ainda mais colocou assim é e não vou
tentar tocar esta não vou tentar
não consegui apanhar três cobras eu sou
o rei e eu sou o rei recebeu a bola e
pitéu há tanto pitéu assegurar aqui pra
mim é tão bom e vou tentar achar que
esta não briga aí
ai meu deus o dólar é filho da mãe tais
como comer olha no que deu está chegando
ela estava tentando tomar nem ela chama
aqui dentro aí não pode ser ela vai
trancar destaque uma pessoa muito
intensa
ela não vai ter com a então é isso
alguns ficar com este vídeo que vocês
acharam não quiserem mais tem ganho nos
comentários
é e quando não é que tudo fique bem até
a próxima